tonight on cbs is the season two
premiere of love island
remember last time it took place in fiji
well
now the island is really a desert and
we're taking you behind the scenes
of the sin city digs
i'm ready to head in there and get my
hands on some boys
i'm definitely willing to step on some
toes and uh link up with a girl you guys
already cast sexy people
these people have now been cooped up in
quarantine and now they're going to be
able to like
touch and hug and do much more with
other people for the first time in a
while probably
there's going to be pda drama
relationships temptation
[Music]
come on come on host arielle vandenberg
gave et a tour of love island's
villa which has moved from fiji to las
vegas
they took over an entire hotel and
nightclub
so this is the spot where couples can
come and get a private escape
the hideaway jackpot this is a secret
jacuzzi
hidden away from the villa the islanders
won't know about it yet but the cameras
will
this is where the islanders work out and
you know fight over each other
especially given the current pandemic
how else am i going to meet somebody i'm
willing to create a lot of drama to be
on this show
i'm willing to break friendships
make new enemies and do anything i can
to find love the reality show is now
airing
seven nights a week on cbs the move to
sin city was to help ensure
everyone's safety during the outbreak
that's the love island bubble we've been
tested and will be tested continuously
we all had to do two weeks of quarantine
prior to getting in here
when we're walking um anywhere we have
to wear our masks so our masks are on at
all times
is the hotel on lockdown when i say
bubble
i mean bubble like no ins and outs
whatever happens in vegas
yeah everyone's gonna be watching
you